un día de permiso por enfermedad al mes
en caso de periodos dolorosos eso es lo
que propone el partido verde francés
Esta es una de las compañías donde ya
está vigente Jessica puede tomarse un
día al mes si siente que lo necesita
estamos de pie todo el día a menudo
cargando cosas pesadas igual que
nuestros colegas hombres y cuando
estamos en nuestros periodos a veces
estamos cansadas y no tenemos tanta
energía
su jefe no tiene quejas
de los 90 días que se pudieron haber
tomado sólo se han tomado 11 y en ningún
momento ha afectado la operación o ha
interrumpido la producción
esta compañía también ha dado el Salto
esto elimina el estrés mental y quita la
presión de fingir que estás bien en el
trabajo
para extenderlo a todo el país los
verdes Proponen 13 días de permiso
pagado al año completamente financiado
por la seguridad social Pero algunos
temen que una ley como esta podría traer
desventajas a las mujeres en el mundo
laboral
la ley podría causar discriminación al
reclutar y promover los empleadores
podrían favorecer a los hombres sobre
las mujeres porque las mujeres podrían
tomar permiso por periodo cada mes
si la ley es aprobada Francia podría
seguir los pasos de España que introdujo
a principios este año su baja menstrual
pagada